Jake:对
Lucia: 是只把一楼这个客厅装饰一下
Lucia: 还是二楼的客厅也要装饰
Lucia: Or also the second-floor living room?
Jake: 就一楼吧
Jake: Just the first floor.
Jake: 然后还有各位的房间
Jake: And also everyone's rooms.
Jake: 我可能找个时间
Jake: I'll find some time.
Jake: 今天或者明天或者等你们收拾好
Jake: Today, tomorrow, or whenever you guys are done.
Jake: 总之就是
Jake: Anyway,
Jake: 这几天我会把整个房子用iPhone扫一遍
Jake: I'll scan the whole house with an iPhone in the next few days.
Jake: 嗯然后各位的卧室就收拾收拾
Jake: And you guys can tidy up your bedrooms.
Jake: 对要扫进去
Jake: Yes, it needs to be scanned.
Lucia: 那你要不扫之前通知一声
Lucia: Can you let us know before you scan?
Jake:对对当然当然当然
Jake: Yes, of course, of course.
Lucia: 对这样我就可以在扫之前
Lucia: So I can move the boxes before you scan.
Lucia: 把那个箱子拉起来
Lucia: I can move the boxes up.
Lucia: 我这没口袋这个东西
Lucia: I don't have a pocket for this thing.
Lucia: 要不然把它拔了
Lucia: Maybe I should unplug it.
Jake: 呃你看一下它有多少电
Jake: Check how much battery it has.
Jake: 如果电很多的话没关系
Jake: If it has a lot, it's fine.
Lucia: 哦我在手机上能看
Lucia: Oh, I can check on my phone.
Lucia: 到它有多少电
Lucia: How much battery does it have?
Jake:对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Lucia: 93%是不是应该可以拔
Lucia: 93% should be enough to unplug it, right?
Jake: 对可以拔可以拔
Jake: Yes, you can unplug it.
Jake: 对你坐着的时候充嘛
Jake: Charge it while you're sitting.
Jake: 然后站着就
Jake: Then stand up and...
Tasha: 但不一定他们俩在一起感觉
Tasha: But it's not necessarily that they feel...
Jake:来这边
Jake: Come over here.
Lucia: 哎他怎么突然变成
Lucia: Hey, why did it suddenly change?
Jake: 昂我看一下
Jake: Hmm, let me see.
Jake: 可以给我看一下吗
Jake: Can I take a look?
Lucia: 就是在我把电拔掉之后
Lucia: After I unplugged it, it suddenly switched to this screen.
Lucia: 他突然变成这个界面了
Lucia: It suddenly switched to this screen.
Lucia: 是哎对
Lucia: Yeah, right.
Shure:  这样你先把这几个对
Shure: So, first, handle these... yeah.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 这个什么意思
Lucia: What does this mean?
Jake: 重开一下
Jake: Restart it.
Jake: 我也没见过这个
Jake: I've never seen this before.
Lucia: 就我把它这样
Lucia: So I just...
Jake:对对对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Lucia: 就是这样关掉 重开一下
Lucia: Just turn it off and on again.
Shure:  哥先先先来这个先先把一根给一边给那什么
Shure: Hey bro, first take this, yeah, and give one side to...
Jake: 好我这出不来
Jake: Alright, I can't get this out.
Shure:  你把那缩一下
Shure: Can you shrink that?
Tasha: 这样这个猪就塞不下他
Tasha: This way, the pig won't fit.
Jake: 这个长度是对的吗
Jake: Is this the right length?
Katrina:  都一样的
Katrina: They're all the same.
Shure:  都是一样
Shure: They're all the same.
Jake:哦OK行
Jake: Oh, okay, fine.
Lucia: 啊出来了他应该还是正常的吧
Lucia: Ah, it's back. It should be normal now, right?
Jake:好对对没问题嗯
Jake: Yes, yes, no problem, hm.
Lucia: 可能是刚才有什么bug了
Lucia: Maybe it was just a bug earlier.
Jake: 或者装饰二楼
Jake: Or decorate the second floor.
Jake: 因为二楼的那个场地
Jake: Because the space on the second floor...
Jake: 就做PPT比较方便
Jake: It's more convenient for making PPTs.
Jake: 就是就可以摆那个
Jake: Like, you can set up...
Jake: 摆摆椅子
Jake: Set up chairs.
Jake: 摆很多椅子
Jake: A lot of chairs.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Lucia: 因为二楼的桌子椅子搬到那边去了
Lucia: Because the tables and chairs from the second floor were moved over there.
Jake: 对所以在二楼装饰
Jake: Right, so we're decorating the second floor.
Tasha: 他们这家该放哪里呢
Tasha: Where should they put this family?
Shure:  是让毛血刷的
Shure: It's for Mao Xueshu.
Alice: 哈哈但我觉得他俩又不像一家
Alice: Haha, but I don't think they look like a family.
Alice: 因为这个角不太好拼
Alice: Because this corner is hard to fit.
Alice: 就比较尖的角
Alice: It's a pretty sharp corner.
Alice: 有没有比较尖的角
Alice: Are there any sharper corners?
Alice: 他的嘴是吗
Alice: Like his mouth?
Jake: 听了一圈了
Jake: I've heard it all around.
Jake: 这一圈很强
Jake: This round is really strong.
Lucia: 但是感觉只有
Lucia: But it feels like only...
Lucia: 只有这几个是比较确定的
Lucia: Only these few are more certain.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Lucia: 我们找到了很多两个
Lucia: We've found a lot of pairs.
Lucia: 两个是一起的
Lucia: Pairs that go together.
Lucia: 但是不确定他们放在哪里
Lucia: But we're not sure where to place them.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Alice:但是找不到他们的家
Alice: But we can't find their home.
Jake: 好多好朋友
Jake: So many good friends.
Tasha: 噔噔噔噔
Tasha: Dun dun dun dun.
Lucia: 哇哎这个真的好一致啊
Lucia: Wow, this is really consistent.
Jake:我去哈哈哈
Jake: Oh my gosh, haha.
Lucia: 你是怎么找到的
Lucia: How did you find it?
Tasha: 他这有两个尖尖
Tasha: He has two pointy parts here.
Jake: 我去这尖尖你能看到
Jake: Wow, you can see those pointy parts?
Jake: 眼神真好
Jake: Great eyesight.
Jake: 我这看不清
Jake: I can't see them clearly.
Tasha: 哦这个弧度我之前看到过
Tasha: Oh, I saw this curve before.
Jake: 有点6
Jake: Pretty cool.
Shure:  人生的最后7天
Shure: The last 7 days of life.
Shure:  来吧立起来
Shure: Come on, stand it up.
Lucia: 会不会是那个鸟翅膀
Lucia: Could it be that bird's wing?
Shure:  哦还有一个是吗
Shure: Oh, there's another one?
Jake: 对还有一个
Jake: Yeah, there's another one.
Alice:完美
Alice: Perfect.
Lucia: 哎棒棒
Lucia: Great job.
Alice:那 说明鸟不在边边
Alice: That means the bird isn't on the edge.
Tasha: 嗯对
Tasha: Yeah, right.
Tasha: 这个这个
Tasha: This, this
Tasha: 感觉这个弧度很像
Tasha: Feels like this curve is very similar
Jake:完了换了
Jake: Done, it's changed
Tasha: 很像
Tasha: Very similar
Tasha: 又咋不像哎
Tasha: How does it not look alike, huh
Jake: 确实有点像
Jake: It does look a bit similar
Lucia: 哎对
Lucia: Yeah, right
Lucia: 这个也是对的
Lucia: This is also correct
Jake: 这是你记住的吗
Jake: Did you remember this?
Tasha: 昂
Tasha: Yeah
Tasha: 然后
Tasha: Then
Alice:这进去了杆不太
Alice: This went in, the rod is not quite
Alice: 像又不太像
Alice: Like but not quite
Alice:这个头
Alice: This head
Lucia: 我们刚才是不是给这个蛇
Lucia: Did we just find a buddy for this snake
Lucia: 已经找到了一个小伙伴
Lucia: Already found a buddy
Tasha: 对蛇跟那个熊猫哎
Tasha: Right, the snake and that panda, huh
Tasha: 怎么怎么怎么弄来着
Tasha: How, how did we do this
Alice: 有人长这样吗
Alice: Does anyone look like this
Lucia: 好像不太有人长这样
Lucia: Seems like not many look like this
Shure:  无敌
Shure: Invincible
Jake: 把它弄一边长是吧
Jake: Make it grow longer, right
Jake: 对那把它竖过来倒过来
Jake: Yeah, make it vertical and upside down
Tasha: 就还剩最后的
Tasha: Only the last ones left
Tasha: 这这两个也没找着家是吗对
Tasha: These two haven't found a home yet, right
Tasha: 还剩最后5个找着家的
Tasha: Only five left to find homes
Tasha: 要不尝试着把它们把这些放进去吧
Tasha: How about we try putting them in
Jake:弄长一点呗
Jake: Make it a bit longer
Tasha: 这些形状就出来了
Tasha: These shapes will come out
Shure: 都行
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm
Shure:  也别太长
Shure: Not too long
Shure:  别比那个黑板
Shure: Not longer than the blackboard
Lucia: 这怎么放能让他不不位移这样呗
Lucia: How to place it so it doesn't move like this
Jake:就这样呗
Jake: Just like this
Shure:  这个还是高
Shure: This is still high
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm
Jake: 这个高一点
Jake: This is a bit high
Shure:  再高一点点这个
Shure: Raise it a bit more
Shure:  啊过了
Shure: Ah, it's over
Shure:  过了过了
Shure: Passed, passed.
Shure:  OK OK好
Shure: OK OK good.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Shure:  yes
Shure: Yes.
Shure:  把它拼上对
Shure: Put it together, right.
Shure:  good good good
Shure: Good, good, good.
Jake:妙啊goodgood
Jake: Brilliant, good, good.
Alice: 这俩像在一块吗
Alice: Do these two look like they're together?
Shure:  人类的智慧
Shure: Human wisdom.
Tasha: 像又不太像
Tasha: They look similar but not quite.
Lucia: 这个好像
Lucia: This one looks like it.
Lucia: 是不是很像在一起啊
Lucia: Does it look like they go together?
Lucia: 这俩嗯
Lucia: These two, hmm.
Lucia: 然后这个如果还在这的话就是这样
Lucia: And if this one goes here, it's like this.
Shure:  师傅你是干什么工作的
Shure: Sir, what do you do for a living?
Jake: 哼哼哼哼修空调是吧
Jake: Hmm, fixing air conditioners, right?
Lucia: 接下来这里还缺一口
Lucia: Here, there's still a gap.
Shure:  先头先头按上去
Shure: Push the top part first.
Shure:  对
Shure: Right.
Jake: 这个怎么看起来很短呢
Jake: Why does this look so short?
Shure:  没有没有
Shure: No, no.
Jake:ok的这确实是有一个
Jake: Okay, this indeed has a bit.
Shure:  OK的OK
Shure: Okay, okay.
Tasha: 我们已经越来越接近真相了
Tasha: We're getting closer to the truth.
Tasha: 对哈哈
Tasha: Yeah, haha.
Tasha: 越来越有拼下去的动力了
Tasha: I'm getting more motivated to keep going.
Tasha: 还有3个人无家可归
Tasha: There are still three people without a home.
Jake: 哎呀
Jake: Oh dear.
Jake: 纯手工
Jake: Pure handmade.
Shure:  你要给他跟下面它是个六六边形的
Shure: You need to align it with the bottom, it's a hexagon.
Shure:  你要找好那个角度
Shure: You need to find the right angle.
Jake:嗯 哦卡死了是吧
Jake: Hmm, oh, it's stuck, right?
Jake: 不行啊卡死
Jake: No, it's stuck.
Shure:  对卡死
Shure: Yes, stuck.
Shure:  你先把那个螺母推进去
Shure: Push the nut in first.
Shure:  然后上面就可以进行下一半
Shure: Then the top can proceed to the next part.
Jake:搜嘎来
Jake: I see, let's do it.
Katrina:  看他只有一个
Katrina: Look, there's only one.
Katrina:  这个是吗
Katrina: Is it this one?
Jake: 对但是你可以把六边形给找着
Jake: Yes, but you can find the hexagon.
Lucia: 这造型会是什么呢
Lucia: What kind of style is this?
Jake:  哎呀这啥呀
Jake: Oh my, what is this?
Shure:  完了你给你给人家伙试试
Shure: It's over, give it a try.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake: 给给果断给给
Jake: Just give it, go ahead, give it.
Lucia: 算了那好像又不是真想要放进去
Lucia: Forget it, it doesn't seem like you really want to put it in.
Tasha: 可是就是会有点
Tasha: But it just feels a bit...
Jake: 都是面点吧甜品甜点甜点
Jake: It's all pastries, right? Desserts, sweets.
Tasha: 这个是在这的吧
Tasha: This goes here, right?
Tasha: 哎是是是嘿嘿嘿
Tasha: Yes, yes, yes, hehehe.
Lucia: 那这个应该就不在
Lucia: Then this one shouldn't be here.
Tasha: 我感觉这个不对了
Tasha: I feel like this isn't right.
Tasha: 对这个不对
Tasha: Yes, this isn't right.
Lucia: 塞进去了
Lucia: It's in.
Tasha: 不对那这个肯定在这
Tasha: No, this one definitely goes here.
Lucia: 这个真的
Lucia: This really...
Lucia: 怎么看都有点像一个猫
Lucia: Somehow it looks a bit like a cat.
Lucia: 或者之类的东西
Lucia: Or something like that.
Tasha: 摸不清这个头吗
Tasha: Can't figure out the head of this?
Alice: 也不是
Alice: Not really.
Tasha: 嗯这是松
Tasha: Hmm, this is loose.
Jake: 可以这是荒野去排练
Jake: It's fine, let's go rehearse in the wild.
Lucia: 无限尝试
Lucia: Keep trying endlessly.
Katrina:  这给我刚刚这个
Katrina: This one just now...
Jake:这还有个缺吗
Jake: Is there still a gap here?
Tasha: 刚刚这个是归谁吗
Tasha: Just now, who does this belong to?
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Tasha: 对呀他们仨是归着的呀对
Tasha: Yeah, those three are grouped together, right.
Lucia: 然后这还有一组
Lucia: Then there's another group here.
Tasha: 这还有一组
Tasha: There's another group here.
Jake: 所以这个是干嘛的呀
Jake: So what is this for?
Tasha: 这个这个有归家吗
Tasha: Does this one have a place to go?
Lucia: 刚才咱是不是他和熊猫也是
Lucia: Just now, wasn't it with the panda too?
Shure:  他是夹黑板
Shure: It's for clipping the blackboard.
Jake:架黑板
Jake: Clipping the blackboard.
Lucia: 不是他是蛇那这个豹子
Lucia: No, it's a snake, and this is a leopard.
Shure:  他俩应该不是不穿一起
Shure: The two shouldn't be worn together.
Jake:咋这么短呢
Jake: Why is it so short?
Tasha: 这豹子这个拼图不好找呀
Tasha: This leopard puzzle is hard to find.
Shure:  看图
Shure: Look at the picture.
Jake: 这是两边是吧
Jake: So, it's on both sides, right?
Jake: 卡住了嗯
Jake: It's stuck, huh.
Jake:  这卡住的了
Jake: It's really stuck.
Lucia: 有没有可能豹子
Lucia: Is it possible that the leopard...
Lucia: 在别的什么地方
Lucia: ...is in another place?
Jake: 不对
Jake: No, that's not right.
Tasha: 这样子的
Tasha: Like this.
Lucia: 哎可以可以
Lucia: Ah, that works!
Tasha: OK
Tasha: OK.
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Jake: 我到那边试
Jake: I'll try over there.
Tasha: 只剩最后两个人
Tasha: Only two people left.
Tasha: 没有家可以归了
Tasha: Nowhere to go home to.
Tasha: 然后我们就可以放到左边
Tasha: Then we can put it on the left side.
Lucia: 他们有没有可能也是在边上的
Lucia: Is it possible they're also on the edge?
Lucia: 这一圈看着还挺像一个弧度的
Lucia: This circle looks like an arc.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Jake: 好起
Jake: Good to go.
Tasha: 这正好还差他一个边
Tasha: It just needs one more side.
Alice: 对其中那个平平的是不是这个
Alice: Yeah, is the flat one supposed to be this?
Alice: 这可能不在那边
Alice: This might not be over there.
Jake: 哦那那个应该是卡在这了是吗
Jake: Oh, so that one is stuck here, right?
Lucia: 这个可能他是一个边
Lucia: This could be one side of it.
Jake: 看起来是吗
Jake: It looks like it, right?
Lucia: 跑了
Lucia: It ran away.
Jake: 他是卡在这了不到啊
Jake: It's stuck here and can't come out.
Lucia: 然后这个在这
Lucia: Then this one is here.
Jake:应该怎么卡啊
Jake: How should it be stuck?
Lucia: 他们他们有点有点像是一个边
Lucia: They kind of look like one side.
Shure:  我想想
Shure: Let me think.
Jake: 我还要看一眼
Jake: I need to take another look.
Lucia: 对他们有点像是一个边
Lucia: Yeah, they kind of look like one side.
Tasha: 嗯好
Tasha: Hmm, okay.
Lucia: 虽然不是100%确定
Lucia: Although it's not 100% sure.
Lucia: 高度有调整
Lucia: The height has been adjusted.
Tasha: 哎他们俩正好就这样子了
Tasha: Ah, they just fit like this.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Tasha:  OK了
Tasha: Okay then.
Tasha: 本来他们俩还分开了
Tasha: They were separated before.
Jake: 比划比划要不
Jake: Should we measure it?
Lucia: 哦原来这个牛
Lucia: Oh, so this is the cow.
Lucia: 底下这里是k塌子啊
Lucia: There's a K frame underneath here.
Lucia: 我就说这个地方应该很好
Lucia: I knew this place should be good.
Jake:应该这样 过不去
Jake: It should be like this. Can't get through.
Tasha: 找了半天
Tasha: Been looking for a while.
Tasha: 这人正好就找进去了
Tasha: And this guy just happened to find it.
Lucia: 歪打正着
Lucia: What a lucky break.
Jake:他的这么放对吧
Jake: Put it like this, right?
Tasha: 现在感觉把边整理整理
Tasha: Now it feels like we should tidy up the edges.
Jake:他是不是这么卡着呀
Jake: Is he stuck like this?
Tasha: 然后再把这几个组进去就行了
Tasha: Then just put these few pieces in.
Jake: 这个是
Jake: This is...
Jake: 忘哪了
Jake: Forgot where.
Lucia: 这些个编的顺序拼的
Lucia: These sequences assembled...
Lucia: 不一定是别的
Lucia: might not be the others.
Katrina:  对他是怎么卡住黑板的
Katrina: Yes, how did he get stuck on the blackboard?
Shure:  是我在想他怎么卡的
Shure: I'm wondering how he got stuck.
Jake: 躺下来的
Jake: Lying down.
Shure:  躺下来的
Shure: Lying down.
Shure:  底下得有一个接着他的地方
Shure: There must be something supporting him underneath.
Alice:这先拿出来一下
Alice: Take this out first.
Tasha: 是不是这样子
Tasha: Is it like this?
Alice: 你觉得这个像不像边
Alice: Do you think this looks like an edge?
Jake: 这个会有卡的吗
Jake: Will this get stuck?
Jake: 这边
Jake: Over here.
Lucia: 也有一点放进去试试
Lucia: Try putting it in a bit.
Tasha: 我刚把哪个取出来来着
Tasha: Which one did I just take out?
Alice: 就这样是不像一个边
Alice: Doesn't this look like an edge?
Tasha: 哎对
Tasha: Oh, right.
Alice: 也像一个边
Alice: It also looks like an edge.
Lucia: 那这里需要吗
Lucia: Do we need this here?
Alice: 哎这个吗
Alice: Oh, this one?
Shure:  这是卡这哦
Shure: This gets stuck here.
Lucia: 有可能把他推过来
Lucia: Maybe push it over.
Alice: 哎拼上了
Alice: Oh, it fits.
Lucia: 哇好厉害
Lucia: Wow, amazing.
Jake:妙啊
Jake: Brilliant.
Lucia: 我刚找到了
Lucia: I just found it.
Shure:  哎智慧
Shure: Oh, wisdom.
Jake: 智慧
Jake: Wisdom.
Jake: Wisdom
Tasha: 哎
Tasha: Hey
Tasha: 我刚刚这样接近真相了啊这
Tasha: I was so close to the truth just now
Tasha: 3个都是来着
Tasha: All three of them
Jake: 牛逼
Jake: Awesome
Jake: 确实牛逼
Jake: Really awesome
Tasha: 啊对
Tasha: Ah, right
Tasha: 就这样啊
Tasha: Just like that
Shure:  下面那个
Shure: The next one
Tasha: 对然后哇
Tasha: Right, then wow
Katrina:  然后下面很正规
Katrina: Then the next part is very formal
Tasha: 像像挨着这个的
Tasha: Like, next to this one
Shure:  必然
Shure: Definitely
Jake:感觉感觉是不是上不去
Jake: Feels like it can't go up
Tasha: 就这个地方
Tasha: Just this spot
Jake: 是不没这么长
Jake: Isn't it too short?
Shure:  那把这个加低一点
Shure: Then lower this a bit
Jake:下去
Jake: Bring it down
Jake:额我们先往下就他勾住往下 往下往下往下
Jake: Um, we'll go down first, hook it and go down, down, down
Alice:哎他俩拼到一块好好好
Alice: Hey, they fit together, good, good
Jake:可以
Jake: Okay
Jake:智慧
Jake: Wisdom
Lucia: 再往好像再往这里推一点点
Lucia: Push it a bit more this way
Lucia: 就是往这个方向推一点点
Lucia: Just push it a bit in this direction
Jake: 哎往上往下
Jake: Uh, up or down
Shure:  就是往下
Shure: Just down
Jake: 下不来
Jake: Can't get it down
Lucia: 对这好像还挺像的
Lucia: Yeah, this seems pretty similar
Lucia: 嗯好
Lucia: Hmm, okay
Lucia: 有可能是
Lucia: It could be
Shure:  太牛了拼好了
Shure: Awesome, it's pieced together
Shure:  这黑板可还行
Shure: This blackboard is fine
Jake: 确实有黑板
Jake: There really is a blackboard
Jake: 他背面就是黑板
Jake: The back is a blackboard
Alice: 他俩是一
Alice: They're one
Shure:  这是粉笔
Shure: This is chalk
Jake: 用粉笔是的他送来几个粉笔
Jake: Using chalk, he brought a few pieces of chalk
Lucia: 哦这样子的
Lucia: Oh, like this
Jake: 这个还能凑一点
Jake: We can fit a bit more
Tasha: 他们是这样子的
Tasha: They are like this
Tasha: 弧形对对
Tasha: Curved, right, right.
Lucia: 有没有可能呢
Lucia: Is it possible?
Lucia: 角度好像稍微有点卡住了
Lucia: The angle seems a bit stuck.
Jake: 放哪了
Jake: Where did you put it?
Shure: 太牛了
Shure: Amazing.
Jake: 放这边了
Jake: Put it here.
Shure: 可以
Shure: Okay.
Lucia: 有点像
Lucia: Kind of looks like it.
Jake:可以
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 但怎么感觉好像不完全对似的
Lucia: But somehow it doesn't feel quite right.
Tasha: 因为这还有这么大块呢
Tasha: Because there's still such a big piece here.
Tasha: 对我感觉会这么一大块
Tasha: Yeah, I feel like it's this big piece.
Lucia: 他们应该都这这
Lucia: They should all be here.
Lucia: 这一块这么不规则
Lucia: This piece is so irregular.
Lucia: 他应该是在中间的吧
Lucia: It should be in the middle, right?
Lucia: 他会在哪
Lucia: Where could it be?
Tasha: 我把它先取出来
Tasha: I'll take it out first.
Lucia: 哎有点像那个地方啊
Lucia: Hey, it looks like that place.
Shure:  our whiteboard
Shure: Our whiteboard.
Lucia: 好像也不是
Lucia: Seems like it's not.
Tasha: 先把他放进去吧
Tasha: Let's put it in first.
Tasha: 好像可以
Tasha: Seems okay.
Lucia: 可以可以
Lucia: Okay, okay.
Lucia: 对好像可以
Lucia: Yeah, seems okay.
Lucia: 哎但这样的话
Lucia: But if so...
Lucia: 这里好像又拼不上了
Lucia: It seems like it won't fit here.
Lucia: 但这两个肯定是挨着
Lucia: But these two are definitely next to each other.
Tasha: 可是这个边不一定对
Tasha: But this edge might not be right.
Alice: 这个边不一定在这
Alice: This edge might not be here.
Alice: 把这个边先拿出来
Alice: Let's take this edge out first.
Lucia: 可以可以
Lucia: Okay, okay.
Lucia: 那就把那个牛和那个啥放一起
Lucia: Then put the cow and that thing together.
Lucia: 然后这个是在
Lucia: And then this one is...
Lucia: 但这个好像是在他的上面
Lucia: But this one seems to be on top of it.
Lucia: 这样子的
Lucia: Like this.
Lucia: 然后这里再有一个
Lucia: And then there's another one here.
Tasha: 这个边也不一定对对
Tasha: This edge might not be right either.
Lucia: 对这个边的位置
Lucia: Yeah, the position of this edge...
Lucia: 是不是不一定对
Lucia: Might not be right.
Shure:  困了
Shure: I'm sleepy.
Tasha: 可是这个边是
Tasha: But this side is...
Jake:几点睡的
Jake: What time did you go to bed?
Tasha: 是一对的呀
Tasha: They're a pair.
Katrina:  1点
Katrina: 1 o'clock.
Lucia: 对这应该是对的
Lucia: Yeah, this should be right.
Jake: 1点
Jake: 1 o'clock.
Lucia: 就这这这一圈应该是对的
Lucia: So this whole circle should be correct.
Jake: 几点醒的
Jake: What time did you wake up?
Jake: 10点睡到
Jake: Slept from 10 o'clock until...
Lucia: 这都是对的
Lucia: This is all correct.
Jake: 啊够了
Jake: Ah, enough.
Jake: 够你睡
Jake: Enough sleep for you.
Jake:怎么困的呢
Jake: How are you still sleepy?
Tasha: 只有这个边和这个边
Tasha: Only this side and this side.
Shure:  五点半睡的
Shure: I went to bed at 5:30.
Lucia: 好奇怪啊
Lucia: That's so strange.
Shure:  七点醒
Shure: Woke up at 7.
Jake:五点半
Jake: 5:30.
Jake:五点半睡的
Jake: Went to bed at 5:30.
Alice: 要不
Alice: Maybe...
Alice: 先把这个不确定的边先给他拿过来
Alice: We should move this uncertain side first.
Katrina:  你五点半才睡
Katrina: You went to bed at 5:30?
Katrina:  那你才是真正的不用睡觉
Katrina: Then you really don't need sleep.
Shure:  整两杯咖啡吧
Shure: Let's get two cups of coffee.
Shure:  不然话你受不了了
Shure: Otherwise, you won't make it.
Jake: 好帮我整两杯
Jake: Okay, get me two cups.
Jake: 走我们一起整两杯
Jake: Let's go get two cups together.
Katrina:  出门吗
Katrina: Going out?
Jake:上楼
Jake: Upstairs.
Katrina:  哎你们有咖啡机吗
Katrina: Hey, do you have a coffee machine?
Jake: 没有没有手动咖啡
Jake: No, no, manual coffee.
Jake: 纯纯手动
Jake: Completely manual.
Katrina:  应该是还有两个花瓶的快递没有签收
Katrina: There should be two more vase deliveries not signed for.
Katrina:  签收的话他就
Katrina: If they're signed for, then...
Jake: 下午会有人带我们去坐
Jake: In the afternoon, someone will take us to ride.
Jake: 坐那个高尔夫球车你看到了吗
Jake: Ride the golf cart, did you see it?
Katrina:  我没看到
Katrina: I didn't see it.
Jake: 没有看到
Jake: Didn't see it?
Shure:  旁边楼上好像比我们热点
Shure: It seems hotter upstairs next to us.
Katrina:  楼上不通风
Katrina: Upstairs isn't ventilated.
Jake: 那怎么通下风
Jake: How do we get some airflow?
Katrina:  这没法通
Katrina: There's no way to get it.
Katrina: 真是晒衣服的好天气
Katrina: It's really good weather for drying clothes.
Katrina: 我的
Katrina: Mine.
Katrina:  现在姐姐会来吗
Katrina: Will sis come now?
Jake:什么谁
Jake: What? Who?
Katrina:  那个短头发
Katrina: The one with short hair.
Jake:哦哦哦他哦
Jake: Oh, oh, him, oh.
Jake:哎呀
Jake: Oh dear.
Katrina:  他们要实验室上班
Katrina: They have to go to the lab for work.
Jake: 对他要打卡
Jake: Yeah, they need to clock in.
Jake: 打完卡就可以了
Jake: Once they clock in, it's fine.
Jake: 他也不一定
Jake: But it's not certain.
Jake:有点远
Jake: It's a bit far.
Katrina:  他们昨天晚上那么晚走
Katrina: They left so late last night.
Katrina:  他们得几点到啊
Katrina: What time will they arrive?
Shure:  12点左右
Shure: Around 12 o'clock.
Jake: 对 12点
Jake: Yeah, 12 o'clock.
Jake: 夜生活刚开始吧
Jake: Nightlife is just starting, right?
Jake: 如果没有这些事的话
Jake: If there weren't these things.
Katrina:  他开车应该还好
Katrina: It should be okay if he drives.
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
Jake: 这些相机
Jake: These cameras.
Jake: 等了大家一个多小时
Jake: Have been waiting for over an hour.
Jake: 总算来人了
Jake: Finally, someone came.
Jake: 我们如果布置二楼的话
Jake: If we set up the second floor,
Jake: 布置点啥呢
Jake: What should we set up?
Shure: 什么
Shure: What?
Jake:  我们如果布置这个二楼
Jake: If we set up this second floor,
Jake: 因为我们活动场地有可能在这
Jake: Because our event venue might be here.
Jake: 因为这边场地
Jake: Because this area,
Jake: 比较大你可以多搬点
Jake: Is quite big, you can move more.
Jake: 椅子把下面椅子都给搬上来
Jake: Move all the chairs from downstairs up here.
Jake: 沙发
Jake: Sofas.
Katrina:  就是介绍产品
Katrina: It's just to introduce products.
Katrina:  包括他们自我介绍在这是吧
Katrina: Including their self-introductions here, right?
Jake:对在这个地方
Jake: Yes, in this place.
Jake: 然后场地可能要搞一搞
Jake: And the venue might need some work.
Alice:只要把它放进去就行了
Alice: Just need to put it in.
Lucia: 耶耶胜利近在眼前
Lucia: Yay, victory is near!
Lucia: 这个地方是不是在这里啊
Lucia: Is this the place here?
Lucia: 那就不不太一样
Lucia: Then it's not quite the same.
Lucia: 不完全一样
Lucia: Not exactly the same.
Lucia: 他就那边大一些啊
Lucia: That side is a bit bigger.
Lucia: 又散了
Lucia: It's scattered again.
Tasha: 你颤音了
Tasha: Your voice is shaking.
Tasha: 崩溃了
Tasha: I'm breaking down.
Shure:  哎我们随手拿的那个咖啡放哪了
Shure: Hey, where did we put that coffee we grabbed?
Jake:啊
Jake: Huh?
Shure:  昨天谁把这冰箱给拔了
Shure: Who unplugged the fridge yesterday?
Jake:拔了没有动他
Jake: Unplugged it? No one touched it.
Shure:  不知道谁干的
Shure: No idea who did it.
Jake:我靠
Jake: Damn.
Shure:  镇的酒都不凉了
Jake:哎来来来参观一下瞅一眼
Jake: Hey, come on, take a look around.
Jake:我这咖啡味已经出来了呢
Jake: I can smell the coffee already.
Jake: 来了来了来了来了来了
Jake: It's coming, it's coming, it's coming!
Lucia: 拼好了哈哈哈
Lucia: It's all put together, haha.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake: 好强啊
Jake: So strong.
Alice:我累死了
Alice: I'm exhausted.
Lucia: 太不容易了
Lucia: It's really not easy.
Jake:窝靠
Jake: Damn.
Jake:   太强了
Jake: So impressive.
Jake: 用了多久
Jake: How long did it take?
Tasha: 不知道
Tasha: No idea.
Lucia: 多久
Lucia: How long?
Jake: 应该半个多小时
Jake: Probably over half an hour.
Katrina:  所以土地公公在哪
Katrina: So where's the Earth God?
Lucia: 哪个土地公公这啊
Lucia: Which Earth God?
Lucia: 他就在边上哈哈
Lucia: He's right over there, haha.
Jake: 这个到时候秀给客人
Jake: We'll show this to the guests later.
Jake: 这个还有点脸面
Jake: It's a bit more presentable.
Jake: 哼这我们拼好了
Jake: Haha, we put this together.
Jake: 然后你们再来拼
Jake: Then you guys do it.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Lucia: 他上面是不是还有
Lucia: Is there more on top?
Lucia: 一个一个笋就这样子卡住了
Lucia: Each bamboo shoot is stuck like this.
Lucia: 应该就这两啊
Lucia: It should be just these two.
Jake: 啊这个也可以研究一会
Jake: Yeah, we can study this for a bit.
Jake: 那这个是不是可以
Jake: So, is this okay?
Lucia: 对因为这个的话那那是他俩互相卡住的吗
Lucia: Yeah, because of this, they got stuck together, right?
Jake: 互相对互相卡一下
Jake: Yeah, they pinched each other.
Tasha: 再互相卡一下
Tasha: Pinch each other again.
Lucia: 哎呦哎呦小心小心别撒了
Lucia: Oh, oh, be careful, don't spill it.
Jake: 放平吧要不行
Jake: Lay it flat if it doesn't work.
Jake:哎这个就合理多了
Jake: Ah, this is much more reasonable.
Lucia: 啊对然后就这样子夹住
Lucia: Yeah, then just clamp it like this.
Jake:可以
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 为了防止它散还可以就先装进来
Lucia: To prevent it from falling apart, we can put it in here first.
Lucia: 这样挡一下感觉
Lucia: Block it a bit like this.
Lucia: 对这样就不容易块就不容易掉出来
Lucia: Yeah, this way it's less likely to fall out.
Jake: 挺巧
Jake: Pretty clever.
Lucia: 哎把这一边朝着另外那一边
Lucia: Ah, face this side towards the other side.
Lucia: 小心哈哈
Lucia: Be careful, haha.
Alice: 土地公掉了不该冒这个险
Alice: The Earth God fell down, we shouldn't have taken that risk.
Lucia: 哎这个拼好蛮好看的
Lucia: Ah, this looks really nice when assembled.
Lucia: 就不知为何
Lucia: Just not sure why.
Lucia: 有种日本服饰会的那种画风的感觉
Lucia: It has a feel of Japanese clothing style.
Lucia: 啊哈哈
Lucia: Ah, haha.
Alice: 这样头挤着屁股的这种
Alice: Heads squeezed against tails, like this.
Alice: 和谐相处
Alice: Living in harmony.
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Jake:看一看有多和谐
Jake: Let's see how harmonious it is.
Alice: 和谐吗
Alice: Harmonious?
Lucia: 特别和谐
Lucia: Very harmonious.
Lucia: 就在我们的这个地球上
Lucia: On our Earth.
Lucia: 和谐共处
Lucia: Living in harmony.
Jake: 哦就熊猫后面他很开心的感觉
Jake: Oh, the panda at the back seems very happy.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈这个表情
Jake: Hahaha, that expression.
Jake: 嚯你们拼的是真不容易
Jake: Wow, you guys really had a hard time assembling this.
Lucia: 哈哈哈是吗
Lucia: Haha, really?
Jake: 看得出来看得出来
Jake: I can tell, I can tell.
Lucia: 尝试了好长时间
Lucia: Tried for a long time.
Lucia: 因为他每个边都要
Lucia: Because every edge needs to.
Jake:就这一些 这一些你们怎么拼起来的呀
Jake: Just these, how did you guys piece these together?
Jake: 这个地方
Jake: This part.
Tasha: 就是找那种你看像这种比较紧密的
Tasha: You have to find the ones that fit tightly like this.
Alice: 头挤着屁股的这种和谐相处
Alice: Heads squeezed against tails, living in harmony.
Alice: 就先拼起来
Alice: Then assemble them first.
Jake:嗯嗯呢
Jake: Hmm hmm
Alice: 然后大块大块大块的看
Alice: And then look at the big pieces, big pieces
Alice: 最后大块怎么拼起来
Alice: Finally, how to put the big pieces together
Jake: 我看上面的可能还好一点
Jake: I think the top part might be a bit easier
Lucia: 是的就找到找到边缘
Lucia: Yeah, just find the edges
Alice: 对这种的好一点严丝合缝对对对就是差不多最后拼起来
Alice: Yeah, this kind is better, fits perfectly, right, right, almost fits perfectly in the end
Jake: 这边缘很难ok
Jake: This edge is really hard, okay
Jake: 这个边缘确实还挺圆的
Jake: This edge is indeed quite round
Lucia: 嗯除了这一块但是后面就是这
Lucia: Yeah, except for this part, but later on, this
Lucia: 这部分拼好之后
Lucia: After we put this part together
Lucia: 我们就发现他这个弧度很像是这个圆
Lucia: We realized that this curve looks like this circle
Lucia: 所以就还是放在边上
Lucia: So we still put it on the edge
Jake:哦哦
Jake: Oh oh
Alice: 哦你看一下
Alice: Oh, take a look
Alice: 一开始这个就不在这个弧的考虑范围
Alice: At first, this wasn't in the consideration for this arc
Lucia: 对障眼法
Lucia: Yeah, it's an optical illusion
Jake:对对
Jake: Right, right
Jake: 牛啊
Jake: Amazing
Alice: 累死的喽
Alice: I'm exhausted
Lucia: 好有成就感啊
Lucia: It feels so rewarding
Tasha: 哈哈哈我不敢想象
Tasha: Hahaha, I can't imagine
Tasha: 如果后面客人来玩这
Tasha: If guests come and play this later
Tasha: 玩一个小时会不会想走
Tasha: Will they want to leave after an hour?
Lucia: 哈哈哈客人可能拼一拼就
Lucia: Hahaha, guests might just try a bit and then
Lucia: 哎呀不拼了我们要下一个节目哈哈
Lucia: Ah, forget it, let's move on to the next activity, haha
Jake:对呀
Jake: 我们琢磨琢磨
Jake: Let's think about it
Jake: 这个要要不看看你的开箱
Jake: How about we take a look at your unboxing?
Tasha: 我的开箱啊
Tasha: My unboxing?
Jake: 嗯你有好多东西要不给我们秀一秀
Jake: Yeah, you have a lot of stuff, why don't you show us?
Lucia: 哎我的刚才
Lucia: Hey, just now
Tasha: 不用吧这做蛋糕的模具
Tasha: No need, these are just cake molds
Jake: 不用秀是吧
Jake: No need to show, right?
Tasha: 4寸和6寸的
Tasha: 4-inch and 6-inch
Tasha: 兰花嘴
Tasha: Orchid tip
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh
Alice:打蛋器
Alice: A whisk
Tasha: 打蛋器打蛋器搅拌棒
Tasha: A whisk, a whisk, and a mixing stick
Jake: 太专业了
Jake: So professional
Tasha: 裱花嘴
Tasha: Piping tip.
Tasha: 薄脆
Tasha: Crisp.
Tasha: 刮板
Tasha: Scraper.
Jake: 这什么呀
Jake: What's this?
Alice:刮板
Alice: Scraper.
Tasha: 刮板
Tasha: Scraper.
Jake:  哦哦哦
Jake: Oh, oh, oh.
Tasha: 啊也可以平的也可以切面团
Tasha: Ah, it can be flat or used to cut dough.
Jake: 明白明白
Jake: Got it, got it.
Tasha: 这个想的是做
Tasha: This is meant to be used for...
Alice: 杯子的那种
Alice: For the cups.
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Yeah.
Lucia: 纸杯甜点那种吗
Lucia: Like for cupcakes?
Tasha: 塔塔粉塔塔粉塔塔粉
Tasha: Tartar powder, tartar powder, tartar powder.
Alice:饮料应该也行
Alice: Drinks should be fine too.
Jake: 30306090120是吧一盒30 买的话是吗
Jake: 30, 60, 90, 120, right? One box of 30, is that for purchase?
Jake: 你 定价多少钱
Jake: How much are you pricing it?
Jake:一般昂十五
Jake: Usually around fifteen.
Tasha: 定价 定价一般15
Tasha: Pricing, pricing is usually 15.
Tasha: 这个是送的哦
Tasha: This is a freebie.
Tasha: 吉利丁粉
Tasha: Gelatin powder.
Katrina:  啊凝固用的
Katrina: Ah, for solidifying.
Tasha: 你要量杯
Tasha: Do you need a measuring cup?
Shure:  咱们纸抽在哪
Shure: Where's our tissue box?
Jake: 呃这边怎么了
Jake: Uh, what happened over here?
Shure:  摆摆桌子上两个不然找纸找不到
Shure: Just place two on the table, otherwise, we can't find tissues.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Mm.
Jake:糖粉
Tasha: Powdered sugar.
Alice: 哎我们的拼图呢
Alice: Hey, where's our puzzle?
Katrina:  在这里
Katrina: Here it is.
Lucia: 哎呀幸好外面有一层
Lucia: Luckily, there's an outer layer.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Alice: 来欣赏
Alice: Let's appreciate it.
Jake: 裱起来
Jake: Frame it.
Alice: 电子秤
Alice: Electronic scale.
Tasha: 还有的袋子呢
Tasha: Where are the bags?
Jake: 这边有很多
Jake: There are many over here.
Jake: 是这个吗
Jake: Is this it?
Tasha: 呃这些对吧
Tasha: Uh, these, right?
Tasha: 用
Tasha: Use
Tasha: 纸杯
Tasha: Paper cups
Tasha: 呃量温度的
Tasha: Uh, to measure temperature
Jake: 烤箱在哪
Jake: Where's the oven?
Tasha: 打蛋器那呢
Tasha: By the mixer
Jake: 那我们放哪呢
Jake: So, where should we put it?
Jake: 我放哪比较合适
Jake: Where's the best place to put it?
Alice: 削皮刀
Alice: Peeler
Tasha: 放这呗我觉得应该放烤箱上面
Tasha: Just put it here. I think it should go on top of the oven.
Jake:这儿这个嗯
Jake: Here, this, hmm
Tasha: 呃微波炉上面会比较合适
Tasha: Uh, on top of the microwave would be better.
Alice:微波炉上面
Alice: On top of the microwave
Shure:  咱这边只有微波炉
Shure: We only have a microwave here.
Jake: 买烤箱了
Jake: We bought an oven.
Tasha: 温度计烤箱温度计
Tasha: Thermometer, oven thermometer
Alice: 黑巧吗
Alice: Dark chocolate?
Tasha: 对黑巧做那种熔浆蛋糕
Tasha: Yes, dark chocolate for making those molten lava cakes.
Jake:嘿租的租的租的
Jake: Hey, rented, rented, rented
Katrina:  好专业啊
Katrina: So professional.
Alice: 这提拉米苏那个对对对提拉米苏的叉
Alice: This tiramisu, right, right, the fork for tiramisu.
Tasha: 还有提拉米苏的盒子哪呢
Tasha: Where's the tiramisu box?
Tasha: 嗯这伯爵红茶包
Tasha: Uh, this Earl Grey tea bag
Jake: 这些东西昨天应该都扫一遍
Jake: We should have scanned all these things yesterday.
Jake: 扫一天
Jake: Scan for a day
Tasha: 这个是那个咖啡酒
Tasha: This is that coffee liqueur
Tasha: 咖啡酒
Tasha: Coffee liqueur
Jake:就是办完我们一起
Jake: Once we're done, we can all...
Katrina:  你会调酒吗
Katrina: Can you make cocktails?
Shure:  我啊
Shure: Me?
Jake: 看起来可以会
Jake: Looks like you can.
Jake: 哈哈哈是吧可以会看起来是这样
Jake: Haha, right? Looks like you can.
Lucia: 最最简单的
Lucia: The simplest one.
Lucia: 买一瓶威士忌
Lucia: Buy a bottle of whiskey.
Lucia: 买买几瓶可乐
Lucia: Buy a few bottles of cola.
Lucia: 然后兑一块就完事了
Lucia: And mix them together, done.
Katrina:  咱有多少个杯子呀
Katrina: How many cups do we have?
Katrina:  有20个杯
Katrina: We have 20 cups.
Shure:  有上面6个下面6个 12个
Shure: Six on top, six below, 12 in total.
Shure:  我靠这什么
Shure: Whoa, what is this?
Jake: 我们架上去吧
Shure:  咱们经费这么充足吗
Shure: Do we have that much budget?
Shure:  我感觉我是不是应该花花呀
Shure: Should I be spending more?
Katrina:   咱都是他的助手
Katrina: We're all his assistants.
Jake: 对这边主要花了
Jake: Yeah, we mainly spent a lot here.
Jake: 花了很有用的很多费用
Jake: Spent a lot on very useful things.
Katrina:  买点柠檬片我来记一下
Katrina: I'll get some lemon slices and write it down.
Jake: 非常有用
Jake: Very useful.
Tasha: 啊对我也要买柠檬
Tasha: Ah, right, I need lemons too.
Jake: 对下午要买东西就记一下菜单吧
Jake: Yeah, just write down the shopping list for the afternoon.
Jake: 或者单写写在这个白板上面
Jake: Or you can write it on this whiteboard.
Jake: 这个白板现在你们都可以写吧
Jake: You can all write on this whiteboard now, right?
Jake: 比较好写
Jake: It's pretty easy to write on.
Shure:  这白板拍一下
Shure: Take a picture of the whiteboard.
Jake: 拍拍完了
Jake: Take a picture, done.
Jake: 我 再拍一下
Jake: I'll take another picture.
Shure: 然后擦
Shure: Then erase it.
Shure: 擦掉吧
Shure: Erase it.
Katrina:  我刚拍了还有
Katrina: I just took a picture, there's still some left.
Jake: 都可以调监控的
Jake: You can check the surveillance footage.
Katrina:  提拉米菲
Katrina: Tiramisu.
Lucia: 哦那个手指饼干
Lucia: Oh, those ladyfingers.
Jake: 对就这么拍一下拍完了
Jake: Yeah, just take a picture, it's done.
Tasha: 淀粉肉松
Tasha: Cornstarch and pork floss.
Shure:  哇真的好赛博呀
Shure: Wow, this is so cyberpunk.
Shure:  看一眼我拍完你的
Shure: Let me see, I took a picture of yours.
Jake: 哈哈哈我记住你了
Jake: Hahaha, I remember you now.
Tasha: 但这家特别贵
Tasha: But this store is super expensive.
Tasha: 还好经费充足
Tasha: Good thing we have a big budget.
Katrina:  哇你看看啊
Katrina: Wow, check it out.
Katrina:  大手套都可以买点饮料
Katrina: We can even buy some drinks with these big gloves.
Jake: 这啥呀酒
Jake: What's this, alcohol?
Jake: 很多酒
Jake: A lot of alcohol.
Jake: 可以
Jake: Sure.
Alice:要啥酱吗
Alice: Do you need any sauce?
Tasha: 切蛋糕胚的
Tasha: For cutting cake layers.
Katrina:  然后这个冰
Katrina: And this ice.
Lucia: 这个怎么用啊
Lucia: How do you use this?
Tasha: 就是你把这个固定器冷冻还是有冷藏
Tasha: You either freeze or refrigerate this holder.
Tasha: 比如说你不是切了一个蛋糕了吗
Tasha: Like, say you just cut a cake.
Shure:  其实也可以
Shure: Actually, that works too.
Tasha: 然后就把这两个固定比如说就固定在第几层
Tasha: Then you just fix these two holders, like, fix them on whichever layer.
Tasha: 然后呢用这个刀
Tasha: And then, use this knife.
Alice:这样横着过去
Alice: Cut it across like this.
Tasha: 对然后他就会切出来很平整的面
Tasha: Yeah, and it will cut out a very even surface.
Shure: 哎不是再往下一个
Shure: Oh, no, a bit lower.
Shure:  哦那不是平格
Shure: Oh, that's not level.
Alice:  手套吗
Alice: Gloves?
Tasha: 无菌手套
Tasha: Sterile gloves.
Shure:  外卖买那边也没多少
Shure: There aren't many left from the takeout.
Jake: 走挂上去
Jake: Let's hang it up.
Katrina: 超市里有的话
Katrina: If the supermarket has it,
Shure: 三四块钱
Shure: It’s like three or four bucks.
Tasha: 黄豆粉
Tasha: Soybean flour.
Tasha: 没了哇
Tasha: Out of stock, huh?
Lucia: 好丰盛的材料
Lucia: So many ingredients.
Jake: 我去
Jake: Oh my.
Lucia: 这个是我的
Lucia: This is mine.
Lucia: 我的眼镜盒
Lucia: My glasses case.
Lucia: 哎这个水是没开的吧
Lucia: Hey, this water isn’t opened, right?
Lucia: 没开的那我可以开一瓶吗
Lucia: If it’s not opened, can I open one?
Lucia: 啊这瓶开过了
Lucia: Ah, this one’s opened.
Jake:对这瓶开过
Jake: Yeah, this one’s opened.
Lucia: 这瓶好像没开
Lucia: This one seems unopened.
Jake:这瓶没开
Jake: This one isn’t opened.
Lucia: 这瓶没开这瓶没开
Lucia: This one isn’t opened, this one isn’t opened.
Jake: 要不贴个名字吧
Jake: How about we put a label on it?
Jake: 有那个小贴纸
Jake: Do we still have those little stickers?
Jake: 还在吗
Jake: Are they still around?
Jake: 嗯已经 找不着了
Jake: Hmm, can’t find them anymore.
Alice: 这好好看
Alice: This looks nice.
Alice: 你可以在这折个角
Alice: You can fold a corner here.
Lucia: 有道理
Lucia: Makes sense.
Lucia: 但是如果大家都折了一个角的话
Lucia: But if everyone folds a corner,
Alice: 不一样的角
Alice: Different corners.
Jake: 那那能记住哈
Jake: That way you can remember.
Alice: 过来有个人是一个斜面
Alice: Someone will have a diagonal one.
Jake: 写一下写一下吧
Jake: Write it down, write it down.
Lucia: 我把外面就撕下来
Lucia: I'll just tear it off from the outside.
Lucia: 给他叠个花
Lucia: And fold it into a flower for him.
Jake: 就在这在这写个字吧
Jake: Just write something right here.
Jake: 哦你还要
Jake: Oh, you still need it?
Lucia: 笔在这里
Lucia: The pen is here.
Lucia: 我先简单在这个白的地方随手写一下
Lucia: I'll just quickly jot something down on this white part.
Shure:  对我明天早上要答辩一下
Shure: Yeah, I need to defend my thesis tomorrow morning.
Jake:好吧
Jake: Alright then.
Alice:划一刀
Alice: Make a cut.
Katrina:  你们必须这么早吗
Katrina: Do you really need to do it this early?
Shure:  我们还有个模拟答辩
Shure: We still have a mock defense.
Shure:  很奇怪
Shure: It's quite strange.
Lucia: 啊你们还有模拟答辩
Lucia: Oh, you have a mock defense too?
Katrina:  论文还没写
Katrina: I haven't even finished my thesis.
Shure:  哦你是软件工程的是吧
Shure: Oh, you're in software engineering, right?
Katrina:  嗯好
Katrina: Yeah, that's right.
Shure:  帮我改改代码吧
Shure: Help me debug some code, will you?
Shure:  到时候哈哈哈
Shure: We'll see, haha.
Katrina:  帮你改代码
Katrina: I'll help you with the code.
Katrina:  我自己代码还没跑完呢
Katrina: I haven't even finished running my own code yet.
Katrina:  哇
Katrina: Wow.
Shure:  出去搞杯咖啡喝
Shure: Let's go grab a coffee.
Shure:  在外面坐一坐晒晒太阳
Shure: Sit outside and enjoy the sun.
Shure:  无敌了
Shure: It's unbeatable.
Jake: 点外卖吗
Jake: Want to order takeout?
Jake: 吃午饭吗
Jake: How about lunch?
Jake: 一点一点不饿是吧
Jake: Not hungry at all, huh?
Jake: 对我们再录40分钟就结束了这一轮
Jake: Alright, we'll finish this round in 40 more minutes.
Jake: 然后40分钟能干嘛呢
Jake: What can we do in 40 minutes?
Jake: 点个外
Jake: Order some food.
Jake: 就是有40分钟外卖差不多能到吧
Jake: It should arrive in about 40 minutes, right?
Jake: 对吧现在点一下
Jake: Let's order now.
Jake: 然后大概准备一下下午买点啥
Jake: And then figure out what to get for the afternoon.
Jake: 在这写一写
Jake: Write something here.
Jake: 拉倒了
Jake: Forget about it.
Tasha: 做东西就是在一楼做是吗
Tasha: Are we making stuff on the first floor?
Jake: 在一楼做
Jake: Yeah, on the first floor.
Tasha: 哦我就是问问
Tasha: Oh, I was just asking.
Jake: 对在一楼做
Jake: Yes, do it on the first floor.
Jake: 然后在这摆这个
Jake: Then put this here.
Jake: 这个就当就是甜点的那个台
Jake: This will be the dessert table.
Lucia: 工作台工作台
Lucia: A workbench, a workbench.
Jake:工作台 和甜点的那个台子放在也是这边是吧对
Jake: The workbench and the dessert table are both placed here, right?
Shure:  不是就是他
Shure: No, it's just...
Jake: 对是
Jake: Yes, it is.
Jake: 这就是一个厨房
Jake: This is a kitchen.
Jake: 全是你的
Jake: It's all yours.
Tasha: 谢谢
Tasha: Thank you.
Tasha: 全开放的那如果那一天
Tasha: It's all open, so if one day...
Jake: 对上面是活动室这边是会议室和厨房合理吧
Jake: Yes, upstairs is the activity room, here is the meeting room and the kitchen. Makes sense, right?
Shure:  我也带稍微带一点
Shure: I'll bring a little bit too.
Tasha: 把所有的模具都放到这个袋子里
Tasha: Put all the molds into this bag.
Shure:  咖啡机就要很大的钱
Shure: The coffee machine is going to cost a lot.
Lucia: 这个哦哦这是
Lucia: This, oh, oh, this is...
Lucia: 这是某位同学的眼镜
Lucia: This is someone's glasses.
Lucia: 我还以为是我们戴的这个太像了是的
Lucia: I thought it was ours. They look so similar, right?
Shure:  混淆你们用的
Shure: Mixing up with yours.
Jake: 把这个擦掉了
Jake: Wipe this off.
Jake: 你们想写就写
Jake: You can write if you want.
Lucia: 眼镜中混入了一个叛徒
Lucia: A traitor snuck into the glasses.
Shure:  AI中混入了一个傻子哈哈哈
Shure: An idiot snuck into the AI, hahaha.
Lucia: 哎这个白板没有背面吗
Lucia: Hey, doesn't this whiteboard have a back side?
Lucia: 只有一面
Lucia: Only one side?
Jake:有背面
Jake: It has a back side.
Jake: 背面是个黑板
Jake: The back side is a blackboard.
Lucia: 啊OK
Lucia: Ah, OK.
Jake: 对可以用粉笔写
Jake: Yes, you can write with chalk.
Jake: 他还给红笔粉笔对
Jake: He also gave red pens and chalk, right.
Lucia: 原来是这样的设计
Lucia: So that's the design.
Tasha: 这个是这备用的一套是吗
Tasha: This is a spare set, right?
Lucia: 是吧
Lucia: Right.
Lucia: 就是那个
Lucia: That's the one.
Lucia: 刀是吗
Lucia: The knife, right?
Tasha: 我靠
Tasha: Oh my gosh.
Lucia: 啊小心手
Lucia: Ah, careful with your hand.
Lucia: 这个挺利的
Lucia: This is pretty sharp.
Lucia: 我们家好像拿这个打过
Lucia: We seem to have used this at home.
Lucia: 果汁之类的东西
Lucia: For making juice and stuff.
Jake: 要不整点咖啡
Jake: How about making some coffee?
Jake: 咖啡整整好了是吧
Jake: The coffee is ready, right?
Jake: 啊咖啡整好了
Jake: Ah, the coffee is ready.
Shure:  咖啡好像没有那么多
Shure: Seems like there's not much coffee.
Jake: 哦哦
Jake: Oh, oh.
Shure: 而且只只能手冲
Shure: And we can only make it by hand.
Jake: 那每人喝一口吧
Jake: Then everyone can have a sip.
Jake: 哈哈哈一小杯就是one shot
Shure:  OK温笑咖啡
Shure: OK, warm smile coffee.
Jake:温笑咖啡
Jake: Warm smile coffee.
Shure:  咖啡也按shot喝是吧
Shure: So we're drinking coffee as a short, right?
Jake: 对对对
Jake: Yes, yes.
Shure:  直接shot浓缩
Shure: Just a short espresso.
Jake:呵呵呵对
Jake: Haha, yes.
Lucia: 我我刚开始点是不会点
Lucia: When I first started ordering, I didn't know how.
Lucia: 真的点过一shot
Lucia: I really ordered a burn.
Lucia: 浓缩上来的时候我都惊呆了
Lucia: I was shocked when the espresso came up.
Jake:哦可以
Jake: Oh, okay.
Lucia: 这是点咖啡
Lucia: This is ordering coffee.
Lucia: 我刚开始不会点
Lucia: I didn't know how to order at first.
Lucia: 然后就是点过那种纯的espresso就一shot
Lucia: Then I ordered a pure espresso, just one shot.
Lucia: 然后上来我真的惊呆了
Lucia: And I was really shocked when it came up.
Lucia: 这怎么喝
Lucia: How do you drink this?
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Jake:是
Jake: Yes.
Shure:  我们现在开始中午饭
Shure: Let's start lunch now.
Jake: 午饭点外卖
Jake: Let's order takeout for lunch.
Jake: 外卖点什么呢
Jake: What should we order?
Shure:  看一看
Shure: Let's take a look.
Jake: 看一看
Shure: 吃的点什么
Shure: What should we eat?
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 美团外卖
Jake: Meituan takeout.
Shure: 美团外卖送啥都快
Shure: Meituan takeout delivers everything fast.
Lucia: 呃那个是干嘛的呀
Lucia: Uh, what's that for?
Lucia: 就是就是用来放它的吗那个垫子昂昂OK
Lucia: Is it just to put it on? That mat, right? OK.
Alice:要不然它会跑
Alice: Otherwise, it would run away.
Jake:呜呜呜
Jake: Wuwuwu.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈他是用来干嘛的做
Lucia: Hahahahaha, what is it for?
Alice: 他的lunch
Jake:打空气的
Jake: To beat the air.
Jake: 要不
Jake: How about
Katrina: 我记一下我要买啥
Katrina: I'll note down what I need to buy.
Jake: 报个菜名
Jake: Name a dish.
Jake:  我请您吃
Jake: I'll treat you.
Shure:  我请大家吃
Shure: I'll treat everyone.
Shure:  何帆不认识饭
Shure: He Fan doesn't know food.
Shure:  牛肉饭加锅炉
Shure: Beef bowl with boiler.
Shure:  小锅牛肉吉野家
Shure: Small pot beef Yoshinoya.
Shure:  肯德基宅基送聚德
Shure: KFC home delivery Ju De.
Shure:  上北京烤鸭老街春饼
Shure: Beijing roast duck, Lao Jie spring pancake.
Shure:  南城香饭香串香馄饨香
Shure: Nan Cheng Xiang fragrant rice, skewers, and wontons.
Shure:  小栋酿猪脚饭
Shure: Xiao Dong braised pork feet rice.
Shure:  酱骨饭汉堡王本味龙江猪脚饭
Shure: Braised bone rice, Burger King, Benwei Longjiang pork feet rice.
Shure:  人民公社大食堂神话烤鱼
Shure: People's Commune canteen, Myth grilled fish.
Shure:  便益坊烤鸭河间驴肉火烧
Shure: Bian Yi Fang roast duck, Hejian donkey meat sandwich.
Shure:  河谷烧
Shure: River Valley roast.
Shure:  日料寿司田老师红烧肉张记京味卤煮
Shure: Japanese cuisine sushi, Teacher Tian's braised pork, Zhang Ji Beijing-style stewed dishes.
Shure:  哈哈哈行是吧
Shure: Haha, alright, right?
Jake:是吧
Jake: Right?
Shure:  他们肯定一个都没记住
Shure: They probably didn't remember a single one.
Shure:  哈哈哈
Shure: Haha.
Jake:自己都没记住
Jake: I didn't even remember them.
Lucia: 我就听到一个KFC
Lucia: I only heard KFC.
Jake: 好那就KFC吧怎么样
Jake: Alright, then KFC, how about that?
Lucia: 不不不我只是只记得这个
Lucia: No, no, I just only remembered that.
Jake:可以啊可以
Jake: Okay, okay.
Lucia: 因为太快了
Lucia: Because it was too fast.
Shure:  汉堡王啊
Shure: Burger King.
Jake: 啊就就肯德基
Jake: Ah, just KFC.
Jake: 就KFC给外国人一些小震撼
Jake: KFC for a little surprise for the foreigners.
Jake: 好吧
Jake: Alright.
Lucia: 我我没有忌口
Lucia: I have no dietary restrictions.
Lucia: 所以大家吃什么都行
Lucia: So, I'm okay with whatever everyone eats.
Alice: 我想吃那奥尔良
Alice: I want to eat that Orleans.
Lucia: 我都可以疯了
Lucia: I'm losing it.
Jake: 好那就
Jake: Alright then.
Tasha: 那把厨具我们都拆一下嘛
Tasha: Let's unbox all the kitchenware.
Jake:kfc
Jake: KFC.
Shure:  KFC KFC全家桶
Shure: KFC, KFC family bucket.
Jake: 呃有些新品
Jake: Uh, they have some new items.
Jake: 热辣不羁全是肉
Jake: Spicy and wild, all meat
Jake: 尊享无敌披萨
Jake: Enjoy the unbeatable pizza
Alice: 用之前记得刷一遍
Alice: Remember to brush it once before use
Shure: 披萨
Shure: Pizza
Jake: 披萨下面全是肉的披萨
Jake: A pizza that's all meat underneath
Jake: 炸鸡炸鸡为对
Jake: Fried chicken, fried chicken, right
Jake: 炸鸡是面皮的
Jake: The fried chicken is breaded
Jake: 那个披萨
Jake: That pizza
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay
Lucia: 衣服没裹上我就先把这个再拔下来了
Lucia: I haven't wrapped the clothes yet, let me pull this out first
Jake:打孔器是干啥的
Jake: What is the hole puncher for?
Lucia: 这样我就可以自由活动
Lucia: So I can move freely
Jake: 哦ok
Jake: Oh, okay
Lucia: 反正这里面垫应该还够
Lucia: Anyway, there's enough padding inside
Tasha: 这个放烤箱里
Tasha: This goes in the oven
Jake: 这烤箱是不是有点歪
Jake: Is this oven a bit crooked?
Jake:那我把他放上面去
Jake: Then I'll put it on top
Tasha: 你那其实把它放上面也可以
Tasha: Actually, you can put it on top
Jake: 好的
Jake: Okay
Jake: 呃
Jake: Uh
Lucia: 需要把要洗的东西单独挑出来一下吗
Lucia: Do we need to separate the things to be washed?
Jake: 好啊啊你们
Jake: Sure, you guys
Tasha: 好的对那这个先不给露西选
Tasha: Okay, then don't let Lucia pick this first
Jake: 额先不给露亚选哈哈哈
Jake: Uh, don't let Lucia pick first, haha
Jake: 哦这个底下哈哈哈
Jake: Oh, this bottom part, haha
Jake: 露西一般不会第一个选是吧
Jake: Lucia usually doesn't pick first, right?
Lucia: 哦对我一般都follow
Lucia: Oh, right, I usually follow
Lucia: 就是follow大家选过的选项
Lucia: 就是点菜的时候好
Lucia: Like when ordering food
Jake:这个眼镜也稍微头发对对对
Jake: These glasses also, yeah, the hair too
Tasha: 把那边先切吧
Tasha: Let's cut that side first
Jake: 先点吧要不
Jake: Let's order first, maybe?
Tasha: 护护色眼镜
Tasha: Protective glasses
Lucia: 这个是不是也要拆一下
Lucia: Does this need to be taken apart too?
Lucia: 就是撒糖霜的那个是吧
Lucia: The one for sprinkling powdered sugar, right?
Shure:  杨老板你你吃鸡堡
Shure: Jake, do you want a chicken burger?
Shure:  吃牛堡哎
Shure: Or a beef burger?
Jake: 我能吃那个披萨吗
Jake: Can I have the pizza?
Shure:  可以
Shure: Sure
Lucia: 这有垃圾桶
Lucia: Here's a trash can
Shure:  有人吃鸡堡吗
Shure: Does anyone want a chicken burger?
Tasha: 好我不想吃堡
Tasha: Well, I don't want a burger.
Jake: 好那你可以吃
Jake: Okay, then you can have something else.
Jake: 那你想吃什么
Jake: So what do you want to eat?
Jake: 你不想吃肯德基是吧
Jake: You don't want KFC, right?
Tasha: 不是不是我不想吃汉堡
Tasha: No, no, I just don't want a burger.
Jake: 哦哦哦鸡肉卷
Jake: Oh, oh, a chicken wrap.
Tasha: 要帮你吗
Tasha: Do you need help?
Shure:  一个奥尔良的
Shure: One Orleans chicken.
Shure:  然后一个
Shure: And then a...
Jake: 好好你帮我推进去
Jake: Okay, okay, help me push it in.
Jake: 我把这个弄起来
Jake: I'll take care of this.
Lucia: 这个袋子要拆掉吗
Lucia: Should we remove this bag?
Tasha: 都要拆的
Tasha: Yeah, all the bags need to be removed.
Jake: 走走一波
Jake: Let's go, let's do this.
Tasha: 呃我先把线扯
Tasha: Uh, let me pull this thread first.
Jake:好的
Jake: Alright.
Jake: 把线洗一洗
Jake: Wash the thread.
Lucia: 这种时候
Lucia: At this point...
Lucia: 我就把它系一下好了
Lucia: I'll just tie it up.
Lucia: 要不然老拖地
Lucia: Otherwise, it keeps dragging on the floor.
Tasha: 这其实还可以烤烤鸡来着
Tasha: Actually, we could roast some chicken too.
Jake: 妙妙
Jake: Brilliant.
Lucia: 裱花嘴一会再拆吧
Lucia: Let's leave the piping bag for later.
Lucia: 别散的不知道到哪去
Lucia: Otherwise, it might spill everywhere.
Tasha: 这这些都是材
Tasha: These are all ingredients.
Tasha: 食材就行啊
Tasha: Just put them together.
Tasha: 把粉的放一起
Tasha: Put the powders together.
Tasha: 食材放一起
Tasha: Keep the ingredients together.
Lucia: OK OK
Lucia: OK, OK.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Mm-hmm.
Lucia: 这些也都要拆掉了是吧
Lucia: These all need to be removed too, right?
Lucia: 这都是粉
Lucia: These are all powders.
Tasha: 粉放到哪里呢
Tasha: Where should we put the powder?
Tasha: 粉就放这吧
Tasha: Let's just leave it here.
Lucia: sorry
Lucia: Sorry.
Lucia: 这可以都给他
Lucia: We can give all of this to him.
Lucia: 塞一块上
Lucia: Stuff it all in.
Jake: 点完了
Jake: It's all ordered.
Jake: 点了几个
Jake: How many did you order?
Jake: 点了个双人餐
Jake: Ordered a meal for two.
Jake: 啊
Jake: Ah.
Shure:  对那是我
Shure: Yeah, that's me.
Shure:  我点了一个双人餐
Shure: I ordered a meal for two.
Jake: 你 你一个人点了个双人餐
Jake: You, you ordered a meal for two by yourself?
Shure:  不是我我和那个
Shure: No, it's me and, um...
Shure:  雨轩对
Shure: Yuxuan, yeah.
Jake: 好吃什么呢
Jake: So, what are we eating?
Lucia: 昂这是那个面包片
Lucia: Uh, this is bread.
Tasha: 电池啊
Tasha: Battery, yeah.
Jake:  是电池啊啊
Jake: It's a battery? Ah.
Alice: 巧克力搁这会不会化呀
Alice: Will the chocolate melt if I leave it here?
Tasha: 我刚刚放桌上
Tasha: I just put it on the table.
Lucia: 要不放冰箱要不放冰箱
Lucia: Maybe we should put it in the fridge?
Tasha: 哦我找着了
Tasha: Oh, I found it.
Shure:  辛苦你帮我通知一下
Shure: Thanks for letting me know.
Jake: 找着电池了是吧
Jake: You found the battery, right?
Tasha: 因为这个电池是我带来的哦
Tasha: Yeah, because I brought this battery.
Jake:等一下啊
Jake: Hold on a sec.
Tasha: 还有套餐吗哈哈
Tasha: Are there any more sets? Haha.
Jake: 收一收
Jake: Let's clean up.
Jake: 没有哎有是是这个吗
Jake: No, wait, is it this one?
Tasha: 那这不就一个吗
Tasha: Isn't this just one?
Jake: 那就没有了
Jake: Then that's it.
Tasha: 那好吧
Tasha: Alright then.
Jake:那还是这个吧
Jake: Let's stick with this one.
Jake: 不用套餐单点一些喝的是吗
Tasha: 好的
Tasha: 喝的不用了吧就
Tasha: No drinks needed, I guess.
Jake:好没了 还有吗
Jake: Okay, that's it. Anything else?
Tasha: 没了
Tasha: Nope.
Jake:别的呢
Jake: Anything else?
Jake: 这些小东西
Jake: These little things?
Tasha: 那我跟着他们吃吧
Tasha: I'll just eat with them.
Tasha: 他们会点套餐吧
Tasha: They will order the set, right?
Lucia: 巧克力是不是有两包
Lucia: Are there two packs of chocolate?
Alice: 我都都不是一个是可可粉一个是可可豆
Alice: No, one is cocoa powder and the other is cocoa beans.
Jake: 来点
Jake: Let's have some.
Alice: 哇都点好了吗
Alice: Wow, everything's ordered?
Jake: 点了三个
Jake: Ordered three.
Tasha: 呵呵但是被阳光晒的话他会不会坏
Tasha: Haha, but if it's exposed to sunlight, will it spoil?
Jake:好那我随便给你点了啊
Jake: Okay, I'll just order something for you.
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Lucia: 那我们要不然就放在啊放在这边这个地方不是不是很容易晒的
Lucia: Why don't we put it here, this spot doesn't get much sun.
Tasha: 粉类可以放粉类可以放在这里没关系
Tasha: Powdered stuff can go here, it's fine.
Tasha: 巧克力我都搁那个那里边
Tasha: I always put the chocolate in there.
Alice: 巧克力我都搁那个那里边了给给我吧
Alice: I put the chocolate in there already, give it to me.
Tasha: 巧克力给我吧
Tasha: Give me the chocolate.
Tasha: 巧克力可以放冰箱
Tasha: Chocolate can go in the fridge.
Jake: 给你一个
Jake: Here, take one.
Lucia: 这个是放在外面还是要放到冰箱去
Lucia: Should this stay outside or go in the fridge?
Jake: 你要套餐吗还是单点
Jake: Do you want a set meal or just individual items?
Alice:昂随便把 我不要喝的
Alice: Whatever, I don't want a drink.
Jake: 你要喝的吗
Jake: Do you want a drink?
Jake:不要喝的嗯
Jake: No drink, got it.
Tasha: 要不这也放冰箱吧
Tasha: Maybe this should go in the fridge too.
Tasha: 没地方放
Tasha: There's no place to put it.
Lucia: 反正冰箱里东西少空间多
Lucia: Anyway, there's not much in the fridge, lots of space.
Tasha: 这个硅油纸谁把它放进去的
Tasha: Who put this parchment paper in here?
Lucia: 这个稍微往边上挪一点好
Lucia: Just move this over a little.
Jake: 来吧到你了
Jake: Alright, your turn.
Lucia: 让我看看大家都点了什么
Lucia: Let me see what everyone ordered.
Shure:  怎么选一堆然后全擦了呢
Shure: How come you chose a bunch and then erased them all?
Lucia: 这个榴莲芝士看着好让人心动但是
Lucia: This durian cheese looks tempting but...
Lucia: 一般来说
Lucia: Usually...
Lucia: 榴榴莲味的东西都有一点奇奇怪怪的
Lucia: Durian flavored stuff is kind of weird.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Shure:  我呢还有一大瓶伏特加
Shure: I still have a big bottle of vodka.
Tasha: 温度放不下了
Tasha: The temperature's too high, can't fit it.
Lucia: 哎让我参考一下
Lucia: Let me take a look.
Shure:  伏特加都比较白的
Shure: Vodka is usually clear.
Alice: 还有一个托盘
Alice: There's another tray.
Tasha: 哎这其实还有个托盘
Tasha: Oh, there's actually another tray.
Shure:  你对啥都基本上喝不出它本来那味
Shure: With anything, you can't really taste its original flavor.
Tasha: 但是桌子上没啥味道
Tasha: But there's not much flavor on the table.
Tasha: 那那要不把这这个给挪开
Tasha: So, should we move this away?
Tasha: 把那个水壶也给挪开
Tasha: And move the kettle too.
Shure:  这是什么呀
Shure: What's this?
Shure:  小潜水光倒了
Shure: The mini diver fell over.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 这就是J人嘛
Jake: 挺好
Jake: Pretty good.
Jake: 我们有几个j人
Jake: How many people do we have?
Shure:  我是p
Shure: I'm a P.
Jake:露西是j人p人
Jake: Is Lucia a J or a P?
Shure:  天啊
Shure: Oh my god.
Lucia: 万不得已才会计划那种
Jake:塔莎
Jake: Tasha.
Jake: 是j还是p人
Jake: Are you a J or a P?
Tasha: P人
Tasha: P.
Jake: p人p人
Jake: P, P.
Katrina: 你觉得呢
Katrina: What do you think?
Jake: j人很j了
Jake: The J's are really J.
Katrina:  我是p
Katrina: I'm a P.
Jake: yfp对
Jake: YFP, right.
Jake: 唯一的
Jake: The only one.
Jake: 站着吧
Jake: Stand here.
Jake: 哈哈哈这个地方
Jake: Haha, this place.
Jake: 这个对
Jake: This one, right.
Jake: 给你一个
Jake: Here, take one.
Jake: 划一个区哈哈
Jake: Draw a boundary, haha.
Jake: 哈哈J区
Jake: Haha, J zone.
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Lucia: 把j人围起来观察哈哈
Lucia: Surround the J's and observe, haha.
Jake: j区p区
Jake: J zone, P zone.
Jake: 看到这个是不是很不爽
Jake: Doesn't this annoy you?
Jake: 这些东西都要把它干掉
Jake: We need to get rid of all these things.
Shure:  好一会我睡午觉就交给你了
Shure: Okay, I'll leave it to you when I take my nap.
Tasha: 不用搁哪
Tasha: No need, just leave it there.
Tasha: 这个也是搁这吧
Tasha: This one too, just put it here.
Tasha: 我感觉这个没这个好使
Tasha: I feel like this one isn't as good as that one.
Alice: 那就给他搁这吧
Alice: Then just leave it here.
Tasha: 嗯行
Tasha: Okay, sure.
Jake: 这个能晒吗
Jake: Can this be sun-dried?
Jake: 这些东西
Jake: These things.
Alice:粉没事
Alice: Powder is fine.
Tasha: 可以没事没事
Tasha: Yeah, it's fine, no problem.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 对粉都晒的晒出来的
Jake: Right, all the powder is sun-dried.
Shure:  阴暗的光保存
Shure: Store it in a dark place.
Jake: 我看一下还有电
Jake: Let me check if there's still power.
Tasha: 玉米油
Tasha: Corn oil.
Jake:有点
Jake: A little bit.
Jake:好 行
Jake: Okay, fine.
Alice: 哎你放那挡着
Alice: Hey, you're blocking it by putting that there.
Alice: 你拿那些就搁这把
Alice: Just put those things here.
Jake: 乱走的p人哈哈哈哈
Jake: People walking around randomly, hahaha.
Shure:  我们在我们在观摩j人哈哈哈
Shure: We're observing people, hahaha.
Lucia: 哎肯德基现在居然还有牛肉汉堡了
Lucia: Hey, KFC actually has beef burgers now.
Shure:  他俩应该配料都差不多
Shure: Their ingredients should be about the same.
Tasha: 到时候就在这裱花吧
Tasha: Let's do the icing here later.
Shure:  对你这这些东西我都拿伏特加对过
Shure: Yeah, I've matched all these things with vodka.
Shure:  都基本是一块
Shure: They're basically the same.
Jake: 我先把这个填起来
Jake: I'll fill this up first.
Shure:  哎呀哎哎呀哎呀
Shure: Oh my, oh my, oh my.
Shure:  哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahaha.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Jake: 你是真多才多艺
Jake: You're really multi-talented.
Lucia: 这是怎么发出的声音
Lucia: How did you make that sound?
Jake: 12个现在
Jake: There are 12 now.
Jake: 环保环保
Jake: Environmentally friendly, environmentally friendly.
Shure:  环啊环保
Shure: Environ-environmentally friendly.
Shure:  不能是吧
Shure: Can't be, right?
Shure:  啊那那不行
Shure: Oh, that won't work.
Shure:  纸杯也就不行了
Shure: Even paper cups won't work.
Lucia: 我好了
Lucia: I'm done.
Jake:好的
Jake: Okay.
Shure:  杯子就再说
Shure: We'll talk about the cups later.
Shure:  先不用买了
Shure: No need to buy them now.
Jake: 我们点了
Jake: We've ordered.
Shure:  点吧觉得差不多
Shure: Order it if you think it's enough.
Jake: 我们总共三个
Jake: We have three in total.
Jake: 可乐也行吧
Jake: Coke is fine too, right?
Shure:  好像是我除了可乐
Shure: It seems like besides Coke...
Shure:  我一会要coffee
Shure: I'll need coffee later.
Jake:coffee
Jake: Coffee.
Shure:  coffee没有coffee会死的
Shure: Without coffee, I'll die.
Jake: 我们要哎
Jake: We want, hey...
Jake: 肯德基是不是不用餐具点俩吧
Jake: Does KFC need utensils? Order two more.
Lucia: 呃咱们早上有剩下的餐具
Lucia: Uh, we have leftover utensils from this morning.
Jake: 哦那就点3个
Jake: Oh, then let's order three.
Jake: 因为剩下的三个是吧
Jake: Because there are three left, right?
Tasha: 啊什么东西
Tasha: Huh, what are you talking about?
Lucia: 哎不记得剩下几个啊
Lucia: Ah, I don't remember how many are left.
Alice: 餐具
Alice: Tableware.
Alice: 动作太大
Alice: Too much movement.
Jake: 好滴点了
Jake: Okay, ordered.
Jake: 大家等饭吃吧
Jake: Everyone, wait for the food.
Lucia: 我们我们要调几种酒啊
Lucia: How many kinds of drinks are we making?
Shure:  能调啥
Shure: What can we mix?
Lucia: 基酒的话威士忌和龙舌兰也可以考虑一下
Lucia: For base spirits, we could consider whiskey and tequila.
Lucia: 没事我投龙舌兰日出一票哈哈
Lucia: No worries, I vote for a Tequila Sunrise, haha.
Shure:  我明天回宿舍看看有什么拿点
Shure: I'll check at the dorm tomorrow to see what we have and bring some.
Jake: 对是的
Jake: Yes, that's right.
Jake:但是一词多义
Jake: But the word has multiple meanings.
Lucia: 如果买了老母的话不买龙舌兰
Lucia: If we buy rum, we don't need tequila.
Lucia: 也行
Lucia: That's fine too.
Lucia: 我觉得风味还是有一点相似之处的
Lucia: I think the flavors are somewhat similar.
Jake: 大概去个两次吧应该
Jake: Probably go twice, I guess.
Jake: 多的话就只能靠剧组带了
Jake: If there's more, we'll have to rely on the crew.
Tasha: 剧组今天怎么不来
Tasha: Why didn't the crew come today?
Jake: 剧组上课去了啊哈哈
Jake: The crew went to class, haha.
Jake: 剧组很忙
Jake: The crew is very busy.
Jake: 兼职剧组兼职剧组
Jake: Part-time crew, part-time crew.
Lucia: 呃兼职可以可以
Lucia: Uh, part-time is fine, fine.
Tasha: 把厨具洗一下吧清水冲就行我觉得要冲的只有
Tasha: Wash the kitchenware with clean water, I think you only need to rinse them.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Got it.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Shure:  精神支柱好吗
Shure: Is that a mental support?
Lucia: 呃如果如果我买了柳橙汁的话
Lucia: Uh, if I buy orange juice.
Tasha: 这里面的都要冲
Tasha: All of these need to be rinsed.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 也可以用气泡酒
Lucia: We could also use sparkling wine.
Tasha: 就是and这一套
Tasha: And this whole set.
Lucia: mimosa也是果汁
Lucia: Mimosa is also juice.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 果汁味浓一些然后酒精度低点
Lucia: The juice flavor is stronger and the alcohol content is lower.
Jake:就过水
Jake: Just rinse them.
Tasha: 嗯对还有这些烤盘
Tasha: Yeah, and these baking trays too.
Jake:哦这些要仔细洗一洗
Jake: Yeah, these need to be washed thoroughly.
Lucia: 我感觉果味的
Lucia: I feel it's fruity.
Jake:这个要怎么洗
Jake: How should we wash this?
Tasha: 这个其实冲一下就行因为也会扑油脂
Tasha: Just rinse it, because it will get rid of the grease.
Jake:昂哦
Jake: Oh, okay.
Lucia: 我们我们好像还有果粒橙是吧
Lucia: We still have some orange juice, right?
Lucia: 那好像不买橙汁也行
Lucia: Maybe we don't need to buy more orange juice.
Jake:那什么这水流挺有意思
Jake: This water flow is quite interesting.
Lucia: 椰汁要不先可以加入一下清单
Lucia: Should we add coconut juice to the list?
Lucia: 然后一会大家考虑一下
Lucia: And then everyone can think about it.
Lucia: 呃我看一下椰林飘香怎么调来着
Lucia: Hmm, let me see how to make a Pina Colada.
Shure:  万能的
Shure: It's very versatile.
Shure:  啊西柚味那个是容器
Shure: Oh, the grapefruit flavor is for the container.
Shure:  这些喝不了
Shure: We can't drink all of this.
Shure:  就当随时的饮料用
Shure: Let's just use it as a regular drink.
Alice: 需要洗吗
Alice: Does it need to be washed?
Tasha: 他说他洗啊洗
Tasha: He said he would wash it.
Jake: 哈哈对对对
Jake: Haha, yes, yes.
Tasha: 休息一下
Tasha: Take a break.
Tasha: 你已经整理过很多东西了
Tasha: You've already organized a lot of things.
Jake: 是的
Jake: Yes.
Jake: 休息一下
Jake: Take a break.
Jake: 拼拼图
Jake: Let's do a puzzle.
Shure: 休息一下
Shure: Take a break.
Jake: 打散了再拼一次
Jake: Take it apart and redo it.
Jake: 哎啊拼拼图
Jake: Yeah, let's do a puzzle.
Jake: 打散了再拼一次
Jake: Take it apart and redo it.
Jake: 为什么
Jake: Why?
Alice: 算了算了不想看见他了
Alice: Never mind, I don't want to see him anymore.
Jake: 休息一下
Jake: Take a break.
Jake: 或者你们上楼或者转一转
Jake: Or you guys can go upstairs or take a walk.
Shure:  装完所有零件
Shure: After assembling all the parts.
Jake: 或者一起帮
Jake: Or help each other out.
Jake: 一起帮他填填白板吧
Jake: Let's help him fill out the whiteboard.
Shure:  我把那个笔记本拆了清灰然后全拆完
Shure: I disassembled the laptop to clean it, then put everything back together.
Shure:  最后都装回去
Shure: Finally, reassemble it all.
Jake: 帮我把这些东西都给扔出去吧
Jake: Help me throw all this stuff out.
Jake: 要不就是没用的东西都给扔出去
Jake: Or just throw out the useless stuff.
Lucia: 对就是这个
Lucia: Yes, exactly.
Jake: 然后他们采购的东西补一补
Jake: And then restock the items they purchased.
Jake:挺好
Jake: Sounds good.
Lucia: 对但是其实也不一定非要放这么多
Lucia: Yes, but actually, we don't necessarily need to add that much.
Jake:对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Lucia: 就是朗姆酒加椰汁兑
Lucia: Just mix rum with coconut milk.
Jake:我去这一锅
Jake: Whoa, that's a whole pot.
Lucia: 然后我个人觉得可能就菠萝汁
Lucia: Then, personally, I think you could use pineapple juice.
Lucia: 换成别的果汁也行
Lucia: Or replace it with other fruit juices.
Lucia: 因为咱也不需要调的那么正经嘛对吧
Lucia: Because we don't need to be that serious about it, right?
Lucia: 所以可以考虑一下
Lucia: So, we can consider that.
Lucia: 对我
Lucia: Yeah, I...
Lucia: 其实我觉得只要有可乐
Lucia: Actually, I think as long as we have cola,
Lucia: 跟任何东西都可以兑一起
Lucia: We can mix it with anything.
Jake: 我们还有20分钟就结束了这一段
Jake: We have 20 minutes left to finish this segment.
Jake: 然后20分钟之内
Jake: And within 20 minutes,
Jake: 呃就就把这些事情都给截掉
Jake: Uh, we should wrap up everything.
Jake: 然后是一个完整的片段好吧
Jake: Then it will be a complete segment, alright?
Shure:  好那我们就这个片段
Shure: Okay, then this segment is about
Shure:  就是5个p人观察一个j人的计划
Shure: Five P people observing one J person.
Jake: 对就是我们现在就收尾
Jake: Yeah, so we are wrapping it up now.
Jake: 就不要开心的事情了就把这个给收掉
Jake: No more fun stuff, just finish it up solidly.
Lucia: 那我们就大家围在一起观察一下吧
Lucia: Then let's all gather around and observe.
Jake: 稳
Jake:settle on after 20 minutes
Alice:我是一个超级超级好的打下手的帮手
Alice: I'm a super, super good assistant.
Tasha: 帮我写一下
Tasha: Help me write this down.
Tasha: 哈哈鸡蛋
Tasha: Haha, eggs.
Jake: 你们要不做啊
Jake: Are you guys doing it or not?
Shure:  鸡蛋每天早上咱们可以煮着吃
Shure: We can cook eggs every morning.
Lucia: 每天早上煮
Lucia: Cook them every morning.
Tasha: 嗯白糖是不是也没有
Tasha: Hmm, don't we also need sugar?
Jake:请坐
Jake: Please sit.
Alice: 有糖粉但是没白糖
Alice: We have powdered sugar but not granulated sugar.
Alice: 可是我觉得白糖其实呃好一些
Alice: But I think granulated sugar is actually better.
Tasha: 嗯买吧白糖还有盐也需要一小包
Tasha: Hmm, let's buy some granulated sugar and also a small pack of salt.
Tasha: 你可以写在一起
Tasha: You can write them together.
Lucia: 要不要一次性餐具
Lucia: Do we need disposable tableware?
Tasha: 盐一次性餐具打算从网上买
Tasha: We'll buy salt and disposable tableware online.
Shure: 不环保
Shure: Not eco-friendly.
Katrina: 不环保那他们那啥吃啊
Katrina: Not eco-friendly, then how will they eat?
Shure:  手抓哈哈哈
Shure: Eat with their hands, hahaha.
Jake:环保
Jake: Eco-friendly.
Shure:  手抓烤出来直接拿那个夹子啪放手上
Shure: Grab it by hand, directly use tongs to place it in their hands.
Tasha: 嗯等一下我从第一个开始看牛奶
Tasha: Hmm, wait, I'll start checking from the first item, milk.
Shure:  还有个雪克锅的
Shure: There's also a shaker.
Shure:  这个这可以
Shure: This one is fine.
Tasha: 淡奶油
Tasha: Whipping cream.
Shure:  晚上整一个寿喜锅吃
Shure: Let's make a sukiyaki pot tonight.
Jake: 寿喜锅
Jake: Sukiyaki pot.
Alice: 鸡蛋没用用无菌蛋吧
Alice: Use pasteurized eggs instead of regular ones.
Tasha: 对用无菌蛋也更好一些了
Tasha: Yeah, using pasteurized eggs is better.
Shure:  那还可以生吃
Shure: Then we can eat them raw.
Shure:  每天早上
Shure: Every morning.
Tasha: 呃鸡蛋汤
Tasha: Uh, egg soup.
Tasha: 嗯也可以买点装饰薄荷什么
Tasha: Hmm, we can also buy some decorative mint or something.
Tasha: 调酒是不是也可以用
Tasha: Can we use it for cocktails too?
Tasha: 薄荷百里香什么都可以
Tasha: Mint, thyme, anything will do.
Tasha: 保鲜膜保鲜膜
Tasha: Cling film, cling film.
Tasha: 这有吗
Tasha: Do we have it?
Jake:没有 呃我没看到应该没有吧
Jake: No, I didn't see it, probably not.
Jake: 露西看过没有对吧
Jake: Lucia, you haven't seen it either, right?
Lucia: 没有应该是没有
Lucia: No, we probably don't have it.
Jake: 应该没有好的
Jake: Probably not, okay.
Lucia: 好的他们这餐具只有
Lucia: Okay, they only have utensils.
Lucia: 比如说那个锅碗瓢盆这些
Lucia: Like pots, bowls, and stuff.
Tasha: 嗯淡奶油
Tasha: Hmm, whipping cream.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Tasha: 鸡蛋淀粉嗯盐盐也写糖牛奶淡奶油
Tasha: Eggs, cornstarch, hmm, salt, salt, sugar, milk, whipping cream.
Tasha: 如果有一小包的奶粉也可以带一包
Tasha: If there's a small pack of milk powder, we can bring one.
Tasha: 一一包奶粉
Tasha: A pack of milk powder.
Tasha: 咖啡粉咖啡粉手冲吧
Tasha: Coffee powder, let's use ground coffee.
Shure:  跟那个不一样吧
Shure: Isn't that different?
Shure:  你要的是什么咖啡
Shure: What kind of coffee do you want?
Shure:  我就要一包咖啡粉
Shure: I just want a pack of coffee powder.
Lucia: 喝的用的咖啡粉也可以吗
Lucia: Can we use the coffee powder for drinking too?
Tasha: 啊对对
Tasha: Ah, yeah, yeah.
Tasha: 啊你们不磨吗
Tasha: Ah, you don't grind it yourselves?
Katrina:  啊我也想买点咖啡茶喝万一嘛
Katrina: Ah, I also want to buy some coffee or tea, just in case.
Jake: 哎我我还带了一个咖鸭
Jake: Hey, I even brought a coffee duck.
Jake: 就是新加坡的一个很很奇怪的调料
Jake: It's a really weird seasoning from Singapore.
Tasha: 也可以再写蛋挞皮
Tasha: We can also write down tart crusts.
Alice: 这个纸箱还要吗
Alice: Do we still need this carton?
Lucia: 这纸箱要不要留一下假如我们
Lucia: Should we keep this carton, just in case we...
Jake: 留着留着对对
Jake: Keep it, keep it, yeah.
Lucia: 假如我们要做一些什么纸箱
Lucia: If we want to make some cardboard boxes
Lucia: 狗之类的可以摆在门口
Lucia: We could place dogs by the door
Lucia: 然后就当迎宾
Lucia: To greet guests
Alice: 那那把纸箱都留着
Alice: Then let's keep all the cardboard boxes
Jake: 对纸箱留着吧
Jake: Yes, let's keep the boxes
Jake: 放在外面没问题
Jake: Putting them outside is no problem
Lucia: 那种那种特别软特别薄的就不需要了
Lucia: Those really soft and thin ones aren't needed
Lucia: 或者说就是破破
Lucia: Or the ones that are torn
Jake:好
Jake: Okay
Tasha: 那有咖啡豆不用咖啡粉了
Tasha: So we have coffee beans, no need for coffee powder
Tasha: 没事我来吧
Tasha: It's okay, I'll handle it
Alice: 就搁这吧
Alice: Just leave it here
Jake:手磨
Jake: Hand-grind
Shure:  我明天我明天明天补给一波装备
Shure: I'll restock some supplies tomorrow
Lucia: 可以查查看那个应该怎么做
Lucia: We can check how to do that
Shure:  我今天回家啊我回宿舍补给
Shure: I'll restock when I go back home, to the dorm today
Shure:  想想啊有音箱话筒然后咖啡草莓
Shure: Let's see, there's the speaker, microphone, then coffee, strawberries
Tasha: 草莓能放
Tasha: Strawberries can be stored
Tasha: 放冰箱的话两三天吧
Tasha: In the fridge for two or three days
Shure:  3天吧
Shure: About 3 days
Jake: 3天我们不会吃吗
Jake: Three days, won't we eat them?
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Lucia: 那就大概过上三四天左右再去
Lucia: Then maybe we can restock every three or four days
Lucia: 买一次对
Lucia: Yes, buy them once
Jake:对
Jake: Yes
Shure:  不咖啡豆我没了
Shure: No, I'm out of coffee beans
Shure:  我需要买
Shure: I need to buy more
Shure:  趁机补给我对
Shure: It's a chance to restock
Shure:  咖啡的一些东西
Shure: Some coffee supplies
Jake: 对我们这边只有一个j
Jake: Yes, we only have one J here
Jake: 然后没有s
Jake: And no S
Lucia: 竟然没有s
Lucia: No S, really?
Jake: 没有s
Jake: No S
Jake: 是我们总共30多个报名的人里边
Jake: Out of the 30 or so people who signed up
Jake: 就三个
Jake: Only three
Jake: 就两个s
Jake: Only two S
Tasha: S是什么
Tasha: What is S?
Alice: s觉得这种事没有意义
Alice: S thinks this kind of thing is meaningless
Lucia: 有可能s比较
Lucia: Maybe S is more
Jake: s是是啥好像是
Jake: S is what exactly, like
Jake: 什么感性和直觉直觉和感觉
Jake: What about intuition and feeling, intuition and sense?
Lucia: 直觉和感觉好像是
Lucia: Intuition and sense seem to be...
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Jake: 就这个实在是没法打官司
Jake: This really can't be taken to court.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 原来如此
Lucia: I see.
Lucia: 那所以是p人更多还是j人更多
Lucia: So, are there more P people or J people?
Lucia: 按照按照就是最终的结果来说的话
Lucia: According to the final result, I mean.
Lucia: 应该报名的时候也是p人多
Lucia: Even when signing up, there were more P people.
Jake: 对对对压倒性的
Jake: Yes, overwhelmingly so.
Jake: 第二个压到
Jake: The second one was overwhelming too.
Jake: 对p人多
Jake: Yes, more P people.
Tasha: 对对对为什么p人多
Tasha: Yeah, why are there more P people?
Jake: 呃
Jake: Uh...
Jake:j人也有一些
Jake: There are some J people too.
Lucia: 这个可以扔了吗
Lucia: Can I throw this away?
Lucia: 这里面还有一个
Lucia: There's still one inside here.
Lucia: 这个也
Lucia: This one too.
Lucia: 应该也是裱花嘴的时候要用的
Lucia: I think it's also used for decorating tips.
Tasha: 对这是转换器
Tasha: Yes, it's an adapter.
Lucia: 那这个放在跟那些放一起吧
Lucia: Then let's put this with those.
Lucia: 然后这个可以扔了对吧
Lucia: And this can be thrown away, right?
Lucia: 那就扔掉了
Lucia: So, just throw it away.
Jake: 就是第一波那个
Jake: The first batch...
Jake: 呃复活节的那一次
Jake: Uh, during the Easter event...
Jake: 呃那报名的里边只有三个
Jake: Uh, among those who signed up, there were only three...
Jake: 只有三种
Jake: Only three types.
Jake: 只有只有三种
Jake: Only, only three types.
Jake: 这个NBTI
Jake: This NBTI...
Lucia: 只有三种
Lucia: Only three types.
Jake: 对总共二十多个十几个人总共三种
Jake: Yes, out of more than twenty people, there were only three types.
Shure:  居然喝了吧
Shure: You actually drank it?
Lucia: 幸好最后我没有复活
Lucia: Luckily, I didn't resurrect in the end.
Lucia: 节举办因为突然
Lucia: The event was held because suddenly...
Lucia: 就是就是突然之间
Lucia: It was just all of a sudden...
Lucia: 我就是那一周事情还蛮多的
Lucia: I had so many things to do that week.
Jake:哦OKOK
Jake: Oh, OK, OK.
Lucia: 然后我一直忙到就是来这之前的一周
Lucia: And I was busy until the week before coming here.
Jake:是
Jake: Right.
Shure:  哎这有一篇那个是
Shure: Hey, there's an article here...
Lucia: 机缘巧合的很荣幸认识大家
Lucia: By chance, I'm honored to meet everyone.
Alice: 对要做那啥的啊
Alice: Yeah, we need to do that thing.
Tasha: 这还可以煮火锅哎
Tasha: This can also be used to make hotpot.
Katrina: 自己搞饭的话那就搞火锅吧
Katrina: If we're cooking ourselves, let's make hotpot.
Jake: 哎对搞一天火锅可以啊
Jake: Yeah, we can make hotpot for a day.
Lucia: 哎对火锅也比较方便
Lucia: Yeah, hotpot is pretty convenient.
Lucia: 买一些简单的食材
Lucia: Just buy some simple ingredients.
Tasha: 火锅底料
Tasha: Hotpot base.
Lucia: 火锅直接煮就好了
Lucia: You can just cook it directly.
Tasha:  丸子羊肉片
Tasha: Meatballs and sliced lamb.
Lucia: 可以可以
Lucia: Sure, sure.
Lucia: 我们自己做饭的环节
Lucia: For our cooking session.
Lucia: 不如就做火锅
Lucia: How about we make hotpot?
Alice: 这是我们买的放进去
Alice: We'll put what we bought in.
Jake: 可以可以
Jake: Sure, sure.
Shure:  他这冰箱全是空的
Shure: His fridge is completely empty.